meet our chemist Harriet she has a
chemical reaction that needs to occur
more quickly our chemist has some
processes at our disposal that can help
her speed up her reaction and she knows
a five ways and to remember them she
thinks back to her days as a high school
student and the day she got a date for
the dance
Harriet was in high school studying
between classes she'd lost track of time
it was going to be late to class
unbeknownst to her Harold who was just
around the corner was running late too
they both sprinted to class and as it
happened sprinted directly into one
another now this is no small collision
they ran squarely into one another in
such a way that he knocked the books
right out of her hand I'm sorry he said
let me help you with your books he
kindly helped her recollect her
belongings and politely offer to walk at
her class and you'll never guess who
went together to the dance
later that year yep those do so as we
can see from this example the key to
getting a date for the dance is to
collide with someone and knock the books
out of their hands now you're probably
already aware that not all collisions
lead to dates for the dance thankfully
the collisions must have two important
characteristics one correct orientation
that allows books to be knocked from
one's hands and to enough energy to
knock the books out shortly after this
incident Harriet decided to tell me her
chemistry teacher all about it I noticed
some interesting parallels between her
story and chemical reaction rates which
happened to be what she was studying in
the hallway the day of the collision
together we decided to set out on two
missions Harriet wanted to help all
chemistry students and chemists remember
how to speed up the rate of chemical
reactions and I being a nice guy that I
am decided to make it my mission to help
create educational environments in which
more both dropping collisions can take
place to increase future chemists
chances of getting a date for the dance
in order to facilitate this improved
dance date getting process I propose
five changes to all schools that
parallel Harriet's five ways to increase
chemical reaction rates first I propose
that we shrink the size of the hallways
this will make it more difficult to
safely navigate the hallways and will
cause more collisions than at larger
hallways and by increasing the number of
collisions we increase the likelihood
that some of those collisions will have
the correct alignment and enough energy
to create a date to the dance
now chemically speaking this is
equivalent to lowering
volume of a reaction vessel or a
reaction mixture in doing so the
individual particles are closer together
and more collisions will occur more
collisions means a greater likelihood
the collisions with the appropriate
energy and configuration will happen
second I propose increasing the overall
population of the school more students
equals more collisions by increasing the
number of particles available for
collision we create an environment where
more collisions can take place third we
must reduce the time allowed between
classes heck let's just cut it in half
in doing so students will need to move
more quickly to get from one class to
the next this increase in velocity will
help make sure collisions have the
appropriate amount of energy necessary
to ensure book dropping this is
analogous to increasing the temperature
of the reaction mixture higher
temperature means particles are moving
faster faster moving particles means
more energy and a greater likelihood of
reaction causing collision fourth
students must stop traveling in packs by
traveling in packs those students on the
outside of the pack insulate those in
the middle from undergoing any
collisions by splitting up each student
has some more area exposed that is
available for a collision from a passing
student when particles travel in packs
the surface area is very small and only
the outside particles can collide
however by breaking up the clumps into
individual particles the total surface
area is increased and each particle has
an exposed surface that can react fifth
and finally we hire a matchmaker is this
colliding and book dropping to violence
is there an easier way to get a date
that requires less initial energy then a
matchmaker will help with this the
matchmaker makes it easier for a couple
to get together by coordinating the
match our matchmaker is like a catalyst
chemical catalysts function by lowering
the activation energy in other words by
lowering the energy required to start a
reaction they do this by bringing two
particles together and orienting them
correctly in space so that the two can
meet at the correct configuration and
allow a reaction to take place so to sum
up if a future chemist wants a date for
the dance
you must collide with another person and
knock the books out of their hands and
if a chemist wants to make a chemical
reaction occur the particles must
collide in the correct orientation with
an appropriate amount of energy and both
of these processes can be Excel
operated using the five methods I've
described
you